老AI全部都封了
鴻海管達偽賺
通通漲停板
更不用說人保一堆老AI
為什麼大漲特長
是因為Dale講的什麼話嗎
不只是
是因為鴻海董事長講的一個神秘數字
EPS13元變20元
這告訴你鴻海還有機會再漲100元
那管達偽賺怎麼辦
那要記憶體就不行了嗎
台資電是否該死
是否該換老AI
該換鴻海
一切一切的哲哲通通預告在今天的節目
大家好 歡迎收看榮耀的紅海間
我是主持人莉莉
投資長 您前幾天就有預告
大牛股紅海會噴出
大部分人都不相信
來 聽清楚喔
紅海間是暫停還是平盤
噴暫停嘛
紅海是暫停
哪個分別是可以預告紅海戰大展暫停的
我親自在變成這樣罵
我說你不喜歡看我的節目退出
我就這樣講啊
我說我有口皆悲啊
我是有口皆悲啊
我是全台灣最喜歡做全職股的分析師
最喜歡做大牛股
因為我覺得全職股暫停
比一般的阿薩布魯股票暫停
更有成就感更有威力
而且才是真正大老師喊手衛解凍
真正大老師就叫台積電掌我叫你掌
紅海掌我叫你掌
國劇我要你暫停就要你暫停
黃酒精聯發科我要你暫停就暫停
這個大牌老師啊
不然我只有一百萬多萬粉絲啊
不夠我塞牙縫啊
是
紅海展庭啊
而且我事前預告
我還說股東會
今天是紅海的什麼
什麼會
股東會
展庭啊
紅海一個展庭
勝過你們其他股票十個展庭
為什麼
你有沒有聽過紅海
有
小孩你有沒有聽過紅海
不要說你沒有聽過啦
依依你有沒有聽過紅海
有
有啊
啊投資票
你敢不敢用力嗎
你敢用力啊
你為什麼不用力啊
因為你不是我會員嘛
大家可以看一堆預告
好不好 我今天太嗨了
來 你說
投資長您連紅海會噴漲停
都可以預測成功您的預告能力
真的太強了
貨員們最高已經獲利25%
這還不是最厲害的
投資長這波最標的股票
就是前兩週跌連好幾天
還叫你一定要用力買的環球金
今天又噴漲停
這週五天的時間
有四天都噴漲停
到現在總共累積8根漲停了
貨員們最高已經獲利快85%
還有投資長的好學生這檔股票
今天也直接噴掌聽
馬上就到賺超過10%
果然是投資長的好學生
真的很聽話
財股越漲越高
還被噴出去的股票只會越來越少
行情是完全不等人的
你手上還沒有標股嗎
接下來就交給我們
經濟日報選股冠軍紀錄保持者
投資者是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析師
郭哲榮投資長
投資長好
Lily 各位朋友大家好
你剛才太High了
我們Come Down 有點快
很多人可能聽不懂
他只覺得我們賺很多
沒有關係 慢慢來
來請看我經濟日報投稿
經濟日報的記者很喜歡我
因為點閱率有時候幾十萬
是
幾十萬
很多人投稿
不是要臭媒
很多人投稿是要拜託經濟日報投稿
經濟日報是希望我投稿
因為我的文章是有Sense的
我都講大型鼓啦
红海暂停就是我成就感
来
我所有会员问你
我就只有一档股票
现在没有赚钱
我跟广达现在赚钱啊
我广达我今天
逢高我除掉
因为广达涨太慢了
我宁愿你放在红海
我都直接跟你讲我不怕
我不怕你学习
我不怕你模仿
我不怕你操玩
我完全不怕
一百多万的粉丝啊
全台灣的粉絲都見證啊
你知道我現在走在路上
很多人會對我尖叫聲你知道嗎
真的嗎 我搞笑 我沒騙你
因為其實大家本來就喜歡我
但是現在大家已經把我當股神了
我看今天紅海也是一樣誇張
你看經濟日報
經濟日報有沒有看到
郭子龍 紅海明天會再噴為什麼
我這幾天就直接寫紅海
我的文章就紅海
你看一下我寫什麼
紅海怎麼樣要開股東會有沒有看到
是不是
是
台積電精彩也是一樣有沒有
本周真正的重頭戲有沒有看到
是鴻海有沒有看到
鴻海的古通位有沒有看到 沒錯吧
鴻海的古通位有沒有看到
我一起啊 鴻海有沒有看到
跟金采什麼一起噴的有沒有看到
鴻海是不是
沒錯吧
這就算了
我昨天還在投稿新聞
他們都拜託我寫文章
國走明天鴻海古通位要說什麼
我說
注意聽喔
劉洋偉將釋出強烈的基本面利多
有沒有講
有
好恐怖喔
劉洋偉將釋出強烈的基本面利多
為什麼
很簡單
因為我說
你要了解對方在想什麼
因為他一定知道
因為我是蘋果代工嘛
是
那我的客人為什麼換了CEO
我最大的客人是誰
除了現在回答以外就是蘋果嘛
蘋果已經在他營收到25%以上啊
蘋果直營長
我只能聽庫可 為什麼
年初本來說不辭職啊
現在被強迫退休啊 為什麼
你看蘋果的市值是漲13倍
很強是不是
不好意思 這我寫的文章
軌軟翻了19倍 臉書翻了27倍
Google和亞馬遜翻了28倍
揮達647倍的市值 股價一直在漲
那好了 我的文章寫得很清楚
本來鴻海市市值第二 僅次於台積電
現在被聯發剋掉
連台牙店都把他當作小弟
他現在變40第四了
你說劉陽偉的成績他很好嗎
沒有人理他
你變老二我交給你是老二你變老四啊
我給你幾億的薪水
所以劉陽偉一定壓力很大
果然不出所難
今天劉陽偉講了一句話
你要懂啊
這個是你要讀通所有的書啊
不是只有技術分析的書這麼簡單啊
我跟你講真正厲害老師就行外都可以暫停啊
講那些股票都阿薩布羅
我都覺得很普通啊
有本事像我一樣
看一下我的邏輯
劉揚偉喊兩個股本賺20元
你知道他現在EPS13元耶
他剛好股價不是260嗎
13乘上20的本益比剛好是260
這代表他20倍的本益比
他今天給你13元的EPS卡
20元代表你目標價是不是400元
市財一定會這樣解讀啊
是
不代表我的立場
我的想法有時候更優
20元乘上20倍本益比就400元
所以今天暫停很正常
劉耀偉在想什麼我都知道
我的邏輯是有故事性的喔
我不是阿薩布魯
國看技術線型噴出了
這太low了你們可不可以太low
不要拿我跟別老師比啊
我是簡直一件事
我所有的股票只有一檔股票
聰明本性這檔股票沒賺錢
其他每一檔股票都賺錢
每一次進出都賺錢
我拜託你會員打我臉吧
我有沒有說謊話嘛
我幾千位會員
我幾百萬會
一百萬多萬粉絲
你去查一下我轉的每一句話嘛
可以查得起進得起考驗
我最近一堆會員加入啊
是
你知道有些我朋友啊
幾十年沒見了
我叫他們不要加入我會員
他們就加入我會員
為什麼
因為我怕認識
在壓力很大你知道嗎
他們又有我而賴
這不然就是我親戚的朋友加入我會員
你知道嗎
我是說你們平常心教好不好
因為我也是說不想報名牌
我就報0050
反正有一賺錢只是賺比較慢而已
我看你真的好激動
這個血壓好高 但是好開心
太開心了
真的開心啊
你看我還直接這個標題耶
你看
鴻海連發科國具環球金誰先暫停
你看點閱率26萬
26萬沒看到
你想你知道國具我已經要賣掉了
連八顆長那麼多
當然是紅海跟環球精
結果黃海跟環球精怎麼樣
這幾天都在長
是
今天都暫停啊
這我的標題啊
折粉都可以
你今天第一次看我
你覺得我在胡扯
可是沒有關係
我100多萬粉絲我能造假
有沒有
謝謝古神我愛折
聰明本性怎麼要噴的
折神預言完全命中
有沒有看到
是不是
精彩跟世界請問是否考慮亂股
這個應該是不知道粉絲還會員
可能就會賺太少
你看現在我的壓力蠻大的
賺太少也不行
人在越南五寒山看直播
恭喜環球星亮燈獲利展廷
這都是會員啦
很多都會員啦
100多萬粉絲見證有沒有看到
125萬有沒有看到
這能造假嗎 莉莉
不行啊
我愛哲這個什麼
拜託你不要寫錯字
好不好
哲哲不喇叭是不是管达也暂停
沒有我管达我今天趁
暂停之前我趕快出掉了我很實在好不好
0050漲好多沒有錯
聰明本性難以膽
你趕快參加會員好不好
一分錢一分貨
沒關係至少你沒有批評我前幾天有沒有批評我
哲哲你不是說紅海暂停
然後咧
我說紅海要噴出了
所以你覺得沒有暂停算我不得
退出股市
退出我平大
我不在講嗎
是
我不缺會員
我現在講話很臭屁我不缺會員
我拜託你 我不學
可是很爽
因為我知道
今天我如果庞安在世 金城武
第二
我股票天天哪也賠錢 你也不會看我節目
相反的如果我長得很醜
我很醜 可是我很溫柔 也不重要
我很醜 可是我很準
你還是會看我節目啊
說我不在乎啊
你有本事跟我對坐
有沒有
你要不要參加的女會員
要是你的選擇
I don't care
為什麼 我有夠準的啊
這幾年最準的這幾天啊
不是以前不準
而是現在有過準啊
現在就是我的天下啊
大型全職股
我全台灣最愛門大型全職股了
你知道嗎
我跟著跟你笑話
我之前不是說嗎
我之前就是有同業啊
一直搞我啊
是
不然就是怎麼樣
哇連同那些什麼
不知名的報紙啊
現在被我告告告啊
告都快不行了啦
你知道嗎
我還要扣掉他的錢啊
結果沒多少錢
我都不知道他背後是什麼勢力
沒關係
我就繼續檢舉到最後
他們就那時候有很多
會員本來是很喜歡我的
被他們搞得很激動
你知道嗎 有好幾位會員
本來很討厭我的
昨天還按
不小心按道你知道嗎
按道說我要參加會員
我馬上封鎖說不要參加
我不讓他們參加啦
他們這些欺我欺的要命你知道嗎
還說這些會員還想告著哲
告著說隱色我
還說我出貨
最好欣欣從70塊出貨到1000塊啦
出貨是這樣出的
拜託我的股票有價有量還出貨咧
我又不是那種阿薩布魯老頭顧
我的股票你們都可以去點啦
人在座天台看啦
我都不在乎那幾億了
再落換台灣50我賺翻了
至少賺到4億啊
不在乎啊
所以你要不要參加規定我不在乎
有沒有
我準就參加
我不準
你覺得賺太慢
拜託你不要參加
很多人要參加
我講話就拽啊
可是我現在有過準的啊
知道嗎
是不是
今天有人猜到了
有人猜到了
什麼股票
好學生今天都暫停了
好學生都暫停了
我還跟你講好學生是名詞
揭開牌的時候是動詞
我不要讓你覺得我現在老頭顧
啊隨便蓋個牌
啊好學生什麼股票
看暫停就說他是好學生
no no no
no no
不用
好不好
哲哲我不用在台積電上班
質疑信貸買台積電有賺錢
他又想房屋徵貸再買台積電
我勸不動
勸不動就不要勸他
就講就好了
那怎麼辦
朋友我跟你講
其實基本上你現在一定要入股市
那我的立場
因為我粉絲太多
我立場一定是最保守的
不要融資
你懂不懂
那真的要融資
你用房屋的
就比如說你用2000萬額度
你用200萬
那額度也不要太高
所以說不要融資
那不要融資的好處就是
萬一真的泡沫破裂了
假如我紅海
400塊我還在買嘛
是不是
那你用融資
你400塊你跌個20%
跌到320你可能就歸零了
可是你縣骨一路做上去了
其實沒關係你還是賺錢喔
那懂不懂
如果泡沫破裂的話
像開始泡沫了
但是泡沫不會那麼快破裂懂不懂ok嗎懂不懂聲呼一下別太激動我也覺得很激動這已經叫言出法隨的境界
謝謝你
好學生哪一檔
我都能猜出來
你猜不出來
我就對你們很好
好不好
管達可不可以在新聞到600 700
如果管達可不可以到600 700
現在 EPS 更好是
鴻海
鴻海已經說200元了
說20元的 EPS
20元 EPS
按照現在本益比20倍不歸
所以他現在會展的
你有管達 你有偽串 你應該先拼紅海
我再講一次
你有管達 你有偽串 要先拼紅海
那什麼時候下車 什麼時候進場
我說了算
你想買一張你自己買
你想買100張 你想賺大錢跟著我
好不好
想到有雙民跑去買紅海 對不對
昨天沒漲 還跑來留言 怪投資長
結果今天展平 紅海展平喔 對不對
是
不知道那些雙民會不會道歉
我根本不希望那些雙民會道歉
我把它封鎖掉
不要浪費我時間
奇怪 成年冷的
你去我不准 你就不要看我的節目
不要浪費我時間看我的節目
你又喜歡看我的節目 想要酸我
什麼都沒有 我又不是一般網紅
我又不是沒有牌照的財經網紅
或者那種根本
我不要講誰啦 我不講很多人啦
我是有專業性的
分析師你知道嗎
說我根本不在乎那些人怎麼想我啊
重點是我怎麼想
從來到我都不在乎那些人
你怎麼懂
人在做天在看啦
我自己認為我至少不會是太壞的人
OK吗
不是会员光看哲哲影片赚钱
废话现在很好赚
现在哲哲股票每一两都赚
怎么办
会员赚得更多嘛是不是
好不好
来来来
今天世界有机会突破金刚吗
哲哲真的准
你看今天留言很多
投资产真的准
真的很准啦
古神班是不是
不幸哲哲快闪开
哲哲是古神
谢谢
来来来
哲哲神好神
我想賺更多 我要加入清代會員
請把我帶回家
你們自己打電話聯絡好不好
來來
來再跟大家講
其他股票我不講了 我太多了好不好
來
我慢慢來給你秀一下這個東西
今天好多人
肘肘好甩 但是我喜歡
真的
我現在不缺會員
你要不要參加隨便你
我甩啊
可是我問你一件事啊
哪個老師有本事
洪海
哪個老師有本事在年初的時候就講
台積電會先噴
結果最後比較瘋狂的事
聯發科
你告訴我對不對
是
沒錯
聯發科耶
結果我錯一個月而已
被人家罵啦
是不是
因為聯發科遲遲到4月才噴嘛
結果聯發科一個禮拜一個月不到時間
一個多月1430元
漲到4690元啦
漲到三倍多啦
1000萬漲到3000多萬
我今天好激動喔
我等一下錄完影
我今天
因為我這禮拜太開心了
賺到錢
我今天很認真開完會以後
我要休息一下
太high了
很high 很爽 很累
可是我覺得很有成就感
很有成就感
你知道點時成金
連八顆噴傘瓶就算了
我連鴻海都可以噴傘瓶
你知道那種成就感嗎
你覺得鴻海或噴傘瓶
除了我預測的力強以外
你覺得
有沒有可能劉良偉也看我們節目
或者看我今日日報的文章
當然是有可能啦
投資訊有100多萬粉絲啊
你覺得拉那麼多
你覺得有沒有中食物去拉紅海
有啦
100多萬耶
台灣股民也才1000多萬
1400萬左右
實際上有在操作大概6700萬
你等於根本就是
1.5 3的人
做股票根本就認識我
有些人是有認識我
但不屑訂閱我節目啊
沒有聽過
我跟你講啊
我跟你講如果你沒有聽過哲哲兩個字的
你股市一定是菜鳥
很爽啊
紅海一個暫停剩你20個暫停
你看我現在我在跟你講環球金嗎
我環球金賺一倍的怎麼樣
環球金賺一倍喔
環球金就跳功鎖死賺一倍啦
四五百塊到一千塊啦
快一百趴了吧
我講是普通位元官普通位元喔
環球金我在續爆
跟你講我現在講環球金嗎
沒有
我覺得懷孕今天暫停對我來說是piece of cake
紅海暫停的死立派
今天你不能講紅海啦
那為什麼今天紅海暫停什麼原因
你我腦袋都知道因為紅海
流量尾是範例多
為什麼流量尾範例多
我已經告訴你
因為看到Tim Cook被趕下台
還看到Cook被趕下台
奇怪咧
蘋果股價一直漲為什麼被趕下台
人家漲13倍
一堆股價漲二幾倍
微軟啊
亞馬遜啊
微軟啊臉書這些啊
回答漲600多倍
你長十幾倍要怎麼樣
所以被趕下台
市值從最大變第三來有什麼用
劉揚偉也危險了啦
你市值第二你現在變市值第四
遜掉了啦
說我是劉揚偉已經放地多了
我連這個我都想到欸
這就厲害啊
技術分析會跟你講這個喔
有啦跟你講說要噴出去啦
可是技術分析不會跟你講要斬平了
對啊
所以是基本面加技術面加籌碼面
加劉揚偉的心理面
我重壓
我昨天還買
我最近在買
我如果沒有記託的話我隨便就買好學生
我就簡訊喔 就買紅海
我跟你講啦 我基本上有時候送題給你啦
拜託會員來來打我臉
我從4月中期以後我幾千次進出期
這麼多檔股票
看有沒有買進幾十檔啊
一二十檔已經正常啦
有沒有每檔股票都賺錢 每一次進出都賺錢
除了扣掉我講的那檔
那個
聰明本性
其實要前提喔
然後4月半左右
買的股票
沒單股票賺錢
幾千國元幾萬次進出
幾十檔股票
都賺錢耶
剛才唯一有抱怨的是錢賺太慢
你們有沒有看到
是
你們不要這樣子
紅衣妮還接暫停
紅衣妮還為什麼暫停
為什麼紅衣妮還暫停
我都按次你說
我不管是紅衣還是紅鞋女孩
這代表一這個字不重要對不對
一不重要
一你這麼重要
重要
這紅衣女孩給你取名詞一一
寫音啊
我是常常紅衣女孩紅鞋女孩
我都不管對不對
所以只要管前面
第一個字跟第四個字就好
紅衣女孩我們念一下
紅衣女孩
紅海嘛
紅海不是嗎
是
就紅海鵝嘛
天啊
畫面給我送分體你也沒辦法掌握住
我進去日報寫文章
我叫我告訴你我每天寫紅海
天啊
我那時候不是頂00981A
我就不懂你幹嘛買00981A
你隨便買一個股票都可以績小比它好啊
我沒錯吧
他們很厲害沒錯啦
00981A引進所有主張型ETF最該買的
該買的
不會比00403還好
我講實在話
因為我人性
因為他們老闆一定派出第一名在第一檔股票
第一檔股票一定是
就00981A
是
第二檔是00413
你看我到我現在邏輯都很難
我到我現在
有時候你不要說我批評人家
你看
他今天漲2.19%對不對
玉山的很爛
你看他2.6%是不是
是不是那個什麼樣
主動統一全球
是不是還是不錯對不對
可是你看他的走勢圖你自己看
你看他的走勢圖
我隨便印單股票就贏他了
環球金有沒有看到
好像五天有四個展停板
是的
我不知道幾個展停板啦我真的很累啦
那這樣展法有沒有看到
然後你說00981很厲害
連紅海績銷都被他強了啦
你有需要擺00981A嗎
你就買你的紅海就好了
通常有親家朋友啊
我問你一下啊
親戚朋友們問你啊
有沒有聽過鴻海
小孩有沒有聽過
有
一一有沒有聽過鴻海
有聽過這個名字喔
有喔
聽過幾年了啊
很多年了
幾十年了有沒有
有
小孩有沒有二十年啊
有 從小聽過
啊
莉莉有沒有聽過
有
啊為什麼你裝不了展停板
因為時間點不對啊
因為你的分析師沒有跟你講
主動會啊
有沒有
他頂多跟你講技術線
你喜歡噴出啊
聽你講這個啊
可是他不知道劉洋偉會講那麼大力多
我說劉洋偉會超大力多
文章有沒有這樣寫 有
我節目有沒有這樣講
不相信來看一下遇到
邏輯啊 你知道為什麼我始終分
你知道我會員最多的
第一個工程師 因為數量大
是工程師喔
我不知道你們有沒有教過工程師的男朋友
工程師就是最討厭人家講廢話
你告訴我答案什麼
你邏輯對不對
他們最喜歡聽我講邏輯
工程師 我最多會員就是工程師
因為數量多嘛
醫生也很多 律師也很多
為什麼他們就喜歡我分析這些邏輯啊
我想很臭屁啊
但是有道理啊
臭屁尿
我們看一下好不好
我們看一下
好昨天講喔
等一下股東外是有熱潮沒錯吧
股東外是有熱潮對不對
是
還是有熱潮喔
現在股東會還是有熱潮喔好不好
明天還是有紅海的股東會喔
你不要看人家紅海這樣好像很慘喔
不過紅海的尾盤是拉起來的喔
紅海的尾盤是拉起來的
所以我告訴你喔
明天紅海再一根你們就瘋款了
欸完全對耶
股東會明天紅海再一根你們就瘋款了
好誇張好投資的啊
還沒講完我要預測 來
明天紅海再一根你們就瘋款了
沒錯吧對不對
我要是留兩尾
我明天一定給你放大力多啊
搞什麼台達電
我欸
你們知不知道
這後面就是我剛才講的
台達電市值都贏他
我是流氧我我一定放大利多沒錯吧
是
跟我講吧
今天暫停的原因就是流氧我也說這句話
當然DAO也有關係
DAO也有關係好不好
因為DAO那尾串長起來
你們懂不懂
來
等一下再跟你講DAO的事情好不好
因為DAO
那個尾串的客戶是DAO
代表AI伺服器很強
來
本來賺13.61元有沒有到
他守住產出新目標
江朝每年賺什麼
兩個股本努力有沒有看到
是
因為他知道有沒有達到20元 EPS不重要
先把股價喊起來
重點就是我知道他要這樣做
紅海AI效益在天場我
董作劉洋偉喊每年兩個股本
來
你知道為什麼我把他管
我在跟你講秘密
你知道為什麼我把管達
我把管達喔
我把他拋棄我說你裡面放紅海來
今天管達老闆是誰
林白禮
你沒關係妹妹你比較菜沒關係這個你比較緊張
沒關係你能回答就回答你不能回答就回答
管達是林白禮
現在老闆就是他嘛
董事長就他嘛
那他
你現在已經七八十歲了
是
有必要有必要把股價拱起來賺錢嗎
好像不用 沒有必要嘛
但是人不需要疊就好啦
但是他就很委屈
但他沒有那個動力
把骨架拉起來
是
好 劉洋偉我認為他也不是很愛錢的人
但是他一定捐念這個位置嘛 對不對
沒錯吧
是
他捐念位置他的老闆是誰
說穿的還是郭台銘
郭台銘一句話還是跟他下台啊 你懂不懂
是
郭台銘一句話還是跟他下台啊
所以
廣達的老闆就是林白領他還在
可是現在董事
紅海董事長是劉洋偉
他背後老闆是郭台銘
郭台銘一定有給他暗示
他自己也知道
我怎麼經營過後
怎麼40第2變40第4
看起來200多元
但我輸人家長很多
所以劉洋偉有特別的壓力
勝過廣達
他的壓力特別大
他的壓力大過廣達
大過偽竄
所以他這次董事會一定要放大力多
這就是我的邏輯
我早就跟你講了
這個
這是天賦你知道嗎
要有邏輯還要想像力
所以有時候問你看到什麼時候講
哪一個董事長EPS3元的
這麼大的
哪敢喊說EPS20元
不是說EPS增加2元
是增加7元
增加50%
因為他有壓力
他股價先拉再說
我節目多精彩
你不要覺得我很臭屁
這個天賦
我怎麼會成為經濟日報選舞冠軍
沒有任何電視才拱我
但看我節目比看中映節目還精彩
我都知道劉雅維和什麼
我這留文放大力多
每年賺20元 EPS 你看
13元對不對 你看一下我們在昨天之前
紅寒多少錢 263元沒錯吧對不對
是
263等於13元乘上等於我們教你數學 我因為不是每個人數學都好43元對不對對不對沒錯吧EPS嘛對不對乘上20倍本益比對不對
等你多少
260嘛對不對沒錯吧
對
我現在的
一樣是20倍本益比對不對
20倍本益比我不要增加喔
我現在13元 EPS變20元多少
20乘20多少
有沒有 這就是他今天展停的秘密
所以禮拜一還會展
有沒有 禮拜一還會展
禮拜二還會展
很快你看不到300元以下的紅海
這才重點啊
劉永偉的利多火完全抓住
所以環球金這個
讓我展停啊
什麼好學生展停
小K
我很感動的是我連
這種首富等級
這種董事長等級的
你懂不懂
他們在想什麼都知道
這是成就感
所以我說老實話
我就算退休我會退而不休
我就是給那種會員帶一帶就好
節目要不要錄隨便你們
我會錄啦但我會只錄給會員
所以看節目一次喔看一次少一次
我媽很擔心
我媽昨天還打電話打了五次
你也有聽到喔
叫我嘴巴不要擦那麼紅
媽媽常常叫我退休
叫我說不要講那種不吉利的話
所以要珍惜子澤的節目好不好
子澤現在也算國寶級的好不好
這蠻精彩的你們不覺得這精彩的邏輯很精彩
OK嗎
所以真的見不到300元的紅海囉
他這個EPS出來見不到300元的紅海
子澤猜人性很厲害 我現在很厲害
你們真的不要被我只能念事
我可以看從你們臉部表情
可以看你們那個像Lily就有好處
Lily就是沒什麼心機啊
我至少看
蠻單純的
雖然他有時候很粗心
這好很單純
OK嗎
這個車員的
我說我蠻要看人的
相信我自身折粉
我再不理你
快五千人的
姊姊不能離開我們
姊姊有錢又散兩
謝謝你們
我趕快救護車
趕快再捐第二台
我不會說話只能幫你按讚
今天快五千人了
熱了
禮拜五快五千人很多啦
四千多還好啦
可是禮拜五這樣算多了
我今天很激動 我看一下
這股市就是這樣子
最近大家都1點半的時候在廁所
2點半也在廁所 你知道是什麼嗎
大家看紙的節目好不好
你們在廁所看紙的節目
拜託留言一下好不好
你們應該不敢留言
2點半 1點半都是這樣子
我說老實話 我講真的很誇張
我現在走到路上 很多人會尖叫 我不誇張
真的假的
什麼真的 真的
下次我要跟你一起走
希望不要人家會誤會我們的
可以啦
資料價如果公私的話
見證真的 我跟你講尖叫就算了
我跟你講
因為其實本來很多人以前認識我
就看著則一樣
因為他們現在原本喜歡我的程度5分
或因為他們股票漲停變9分10分
是
這我跟你講真的
我跟你講真的是誇張的事喔
我今天我跟你講
雖然我今天可以收會員
我可以賺很多錢
但我不是以收會員為主
我希望是大家把我真的是
你能真心感受到我幫你當朋友
就是第一件事情
你們行情越大
你們約要保守
我保守的是股票可以all in
但不要去放大槓桿
不要去借錢
我已經講過了
我每天會講一次
雖然講這麼多
可能會因為這樣子
我少收了一點會員
少收了一點會費
沒關係
可是至少我做到我已經基金的責任
這是我要講
第二個不要辭掉工作
除非你真的很討厭工作
就是你們不能以為每天這麼好賺
明年不一定這麼好賺
所以你能做的是現在當下把握
right now
你不要那麼激進了
去用槓桿
你也不要那麼激進
你覺得每天都行情那麼好
我們現在只有現在
因為我家裡昨天管理員
跟我講說
他說我要辭職了
為什麼
我要辭職了
因為我最近股票賺太多了
好被動生那麼多
真的啦
所以網路上說什麼什麼
二十幾萬三幾萬要離職
或者什麼
我想說
你怎麼天真
現在賺那麼多不代表
以後賺那麼多
他說好幾年都賺那麼多
你們股市這幾年都大多頭
這五年都大多頭
你們真的
就是台積電上班的工程師你們
不要因為
魏哲家最近分紅比例從12%變10%
你們就生氣好不好
你們還是要
冷氣吞聲一下
有工作是好事啊
而且工作
就不會老人癡呆啦真的啦好不好
你要退休你還是要找事做
除非你退休你知道你喜歡做什麼事
我退休我就每天
我一定會運動
像飛哥我們有些人就是有些人
我一定會運動我知道我的興趣
如果你沒有特別的興趣你每天要
安排你的頭腦運動
身體運動那就工作
好不好
你看講這東西其實跟收費也沒有關係
可是我扮你當朋友
好不好
你要做的是現在把握行情
不要去想以後的事情
好不好
不要覺得這每天都是一樣
可是就是因為他不是每天都一樣
你跟他把握住行情
你聽懂嗎
真的很好賺的
真的很好賺
今天外資你看神經病了
買800多億啦
所以今天外資買800多億
他空單6萬口我覺得很正常
你知道嗎
是
因為他買了很多你知道嗎
ok嗎
這都預告在前面
那等一下我給我休息一下
我等一下開始要先排了
我剛才先的紅衣女孩吧
我還沒有先展平板的誰
好學生喔
蛤 同志長
您真的要先嗎
哎呀 先的沒關係啦
反正我們一定賺1-20%了
Gammon
他們要賺那個魚尾Gammon
欸不一定魚尾的
魚尾有時候很長嘛
是
先就先
那你們知道我厲害
等一下我先一檔
漂亮 最漂亮的標股
休息一下 麻煩
同志長 大家都好奇的好學生
究竟是哪一檔呢
您真的要跟大家說嗎
要要要先排啦 好不好
因為我有新的股票了
只是你不覺得我現在蓋排股
真的是百分之百的命中率
只剩一斬嘛
聰明本性好不好
是
來齁
來看有人說我在上班時間偷看哲哲
然後再大便
真的你在廁所對不對
偷偷的馬桶比較舒服一點
剛接觸股市就知道哲哲了
很多人留言好不好
有沒有
以前買到現在1000張
哲哲好神價大家買尾串
對啊但我後來是不是有改變
我一回說尾串嘛
二回說管達是老大嘛
我後來說我紅海是好大
我有變來變去
可是變來變去
節奏都蠻對的
好不好
摩托老師的股票也都很強
對他很厲害
但沒有整個股票強的誇張
他們都很優秀
只是最近我是股神
真的啦
摩托老師都很優秀
而且都很認真在上班
真的摩托老師很認真上班
有些老師啦
我不敢講
我不要講誰
我不會講誰
我們要批評
因為我覺得現在頭顧帳很好
大家都賺到錢了
也不會批評
你們知道批評的話
就像那個批評我那位分析師一樣
搞得業績沒有比較好
財報變不好 身體變不好
何必呢 還不是普通不好是非常不好
何必呢
我還沒告完他咧 你知道嗎
我把幕後的黑手
還有人的廣告公司
幕後黑手我該告要告
這根本不在乎律師費
幾百萬 幾千萬律師費我都在乎
我精高從業
我這個人就是對就對 錯就錯
我做錯 我一定認錯
你說我錯 我一定認錯
有沒有 有時候
因為你還參與
不知道有些老闆老師真的臉皮很厚
錯了 才你不能認錯
我說我是不是搞錯了
有時候因為我有講錯話
可是我說我認了
我是常常這樣對不對
是沒錯吧對不對
有時候但因為我有時候
我有點過重
有時候會講A講B 講A講B
反正那不是重點
重點是
我認錯了認錯
扯遠了我不扯遠了
反正我告訴大家
某個老師都蠻強的啦
好不好這邊有講
某個老師都蠻強的
只是整個最近真的比較強一點點
好不好
這是真的喔
這真的公司的 HR 恨子哲哲了
因為賺太多很多人要退休
不要啦不要退休 不要那麼快
可以解決一下偉串
偉串不錯 我覺得紅海比較厲害
因為紅海是地多
偉串是因為 Dale 的關係
沒有 是因為我們快速講一下好不好
因為我做很多次講不完 真的不好意思
因為我覺得今天最乏來的是
我知道劉洋偉在想什麼
不然劉洋偉以前講話會那麼刺激嗎
一定有壓力嘛
是不是我講沒錯吧
是
我們快速看一下這個
這個為什麼 Dale 會漲
因為 Dale 的
Dale的訂單大部分就交給
偉串嘛對不對
所以Dale有一個大訂單說業務暴增了
好像股價漲了40%
那Dale股價漲那麼多還有什麼原因
第一個營收好
第一個什麼
第二個這個大概占30%
就是
他是
川普的大金主你不知道對不對
Dale是川普大金主
捐了幾千億以上
很誇張幾百億幾千億
如果沒記錯的數字的話
那時候看到數字很誇張
好
所以川普也幫他喊話
幫他喊話
Dale夫婦
他們川辦人
所以幫他喊股票
所以Dale營收又不錯
QR營收年增進求10%有沒有看到
旁後股價30%
不是40% 30%
有沒有看到
這個預估本來2.9變4.86
你很誇張有沒有
增加了50%
增加了快60%了
是
那就跟那個紅海一樣
也增加5 60%
是不是
所以後來展一根展停榜還好
你聽得懂嗎
後來如果說這13元變20元
然後AI伺服器有沒有看到
前年相關的AI預測有沒有看到
再調整嘛是不是
500億的美金變600億啊
是不是
那Dale台灣的收費股是誰
偽創人保營業達華碩技嘉
我的好學生在其中一檔
說為什麼營業達長進去
人保長進去嘛
這個營收都出來了嘛
但懂不懂
可是只有Dale會做AI伺服器嗎
NO
所以廣達偉唱也會長
AI是這個 所以你們很幸福
你要記得這一批
這個時候你們要把錢存下來
你們一定要 這個就像90年代的日本
淘金時代 他最會泡沫
一定會 可是你現在 你只要記得這件事
可是不是叫你現在 Stop
喔 捨著做泡沫 所以我要買股票
NO NO NO
你現在少賺 就是這種被人家剝奪
你會被人家笑
真的 可是你風險要控制 不要去槓桿
所以這AI很恐怖
這是剛開始而已
瘋狂剛開始
好不好你們何其幸福
這30年功力
你現在繳三個月半年的會費
我30年功力台股最精華
我感覺比12682
那時候我很小
我感覺比12682還瘋狂的時候
你知道嗎
12682只是一個台灣的資金題材而已
現在是台灣世界的中心
何其何能
何其何德
應該說何其有幸
你參與到他
你每個人只要願意把錢放在股市
你就是台積電位置叫那個老闆
應該說股東
你就是那些員工的老闆
懂嗎
好不好
還仁勳台灣不可能不成長
我應該臨時叫你參一首歌
不可能愛上你對不對
不會喔
不會
你不會 好啦算了
不可能不成長 有沒有看到
有兩個不不
就是我跟妳講 No No No
所以這個也是我為什麼說這個人保嗎
所以人保的走勢圖也很漂亮喔
其實人保我會想再買 只是我最近買太多股票了
最近幾天不是有人問我人保的現實好不好看
我說不好看 今天就好看了
今天就好看了
可是他沒有 其實全部裡面
全部裡面老AI最好看的是紅海
來我再給你冷靜一下喔
因為全部裡面示範最大的利多是紅海
因為就是那一句話
記得一句話
從13元的EPS 變20元 EPS
13元乘上20倍本益比是260
等於昨天的股價
20元的EPS 乘上20倍本益比
他本益比沒必要降低啊
沒理由啊我說的沒錯吧
所以400元
好 400元我打個9折360
我認為禮拜一還會續展
你應該是禮拜一就看不到
我講禮拜一看不到300元的
可能看不到300元的紅白拍
那是至少要漲4-5%
我敢壓住他 我就有機會
你看我到現在還沒跟你講環球金
我賺了多少
因為我的成就感是來自於這種
就是這種大家都可以賺錢的股票
你知道嗎 我很開心
紅外展停
我先練一下紅外 賺25%
禮拜一可能算30-40%
我的股票都在慢慢漲
一下長很好
好學生先不要先開牌
這樣跳過來
先看一下
環球精是選美小姐
你看我蓋牌股
我什麼選美小姐
紅衣尼還是紅海
對你多好
這是
紅衣尼還是紅海間斬停
環球精一根斬停
兩根斬停
三根斬停
四根斬停
五根斬停
六根斬停
七根斬停
八根斬停
本來四五百元
現在幾千塊
破千
來我賺了85%
聯發科100多%
國劇差不多100%
再來一檔一倍的
一倍一倍再一倍
100萬
一倍200萬
再一倍400萬
再一倍800萬
再一倍1600萬
可以退休了吧至少半退休啊對不對一半退休啊是一倍一倍就這樣很難嗎以前很難現在很簡單我得講事實
五天有四天奔展廳啦
我講的就是紅海
我現在四天奔展廳沒什麼
塞牙縫啊
剛好夠我塞啦
知道嗎
紅海這種股票是我喜歡的
因為你們都聽過
你們都沒買到
你看到展廳就很生氣對不對
參加我會員啦
你會好會演啦
你就不會生氣了
懂嗎
最高的印賺50% 85%
我實際上有拿12005%或綠G8
來看一下環球晶喔
我今天真的沒有時間一直播重播
可是要環球晶
最拽的地方這邊
來來來這邊
等一下
幾分啊
小汗
5月15號
等於兩週前而已啊對不對
沒錯啊
是
三三禮拜五嘛對不對
你看一下喔 有一檔股票那天跌停板
有一檔股票那天跌停板 看一下
列仙境 6488 環球晶
今天給我跌停板喔 環球晶再跌沒關係我要買喔
環球晶再跌我真的要買喔 算不夠多 反正算48%嘛
他再一根我一定要買 我是認真的
對環球晶絕對是利多
對環球晶不一定是利多 為什麼
是不是
我說我講三次 再跌我一定要買
那時700多塊
所以你可以買到600多塊的
現在1000塊啦
如果照我說你看節目都可以賺6、70%
真的
所以你看我有些股票你看
3037星星啊
不是晃晃晃
有啦1000多塊啦
你最好賺了一段沒啦
你懂我意思吧
那時候6、700塊我說差不多了
很多人說笑我為什麼要笑的
我一檔股票每一檔股票都比星星飆
他生好笑 七十五年笑我
後面我留給別人賺
國具也是一樣啊
國具今天跌了啊 有用嗎
上禮拜我就說賣掉了
你要幹什麼 我是上禮拜什麼時候
對上禮拜了 是不是 你這把換掉
國具買個環球巾都展得比國具強啊
五天四個展平板的
你買紅藍你今天都開心啊
睡覺都睡不好覺為什麼
睡覺的時候流口水啊 一直在笑啊
你老婆醒來看你幹嘛在笑啊
我夢見兩個男人幫助我們人生
第一個是劉洋偉 第二個是哲哲
好啦
希望你喜歡我講的幹話
有沒有開心
開心啦
有沒有合得合能
大家合得合能
我也合得合能
能參與這樣子史上這大行程
他們喔
那些人是出錢又出力
你只要把錢放著
你就可以享受他們的榮幸
想問他AI
而且你現在買
我真的覺得很好笑
有一群人那時候之前還很氣我
還想告哲哲的
我昨天還不小心看到
要參加會員的
拜託你不要參加
你不要恨我就好
你也不要參加
拜託
你們那種想法錯誤的人
拜託不要再參加
我投顧老師裡面
現在我認為我計較最好
新地位認為我數一數二好
那時候只是股價不如預期
被我罵成這樣子
哪一檔股票
大部分股票放到現在哪一檔不是噴出
哪一檔嗎
你不要說100檔都是100檔
100檔也有95檔
而且都不是攢一倍的
很多都攢好幾倍
欣欣那時候
去年被人家罵到現在
70塊
現在1000塊
你有什麼資格罵我
是不是
人在做天在看
我不缺會員
拜託那些不喜歡我的
就不要再喜歡我了
這就是不缺錢
可是我答應你
就是因為我不缺錢
所以我會用盡我一生
好好的保护你
为什么
因为为钱做事情
你不一定会开心
为了理想
为了兴趣做事情
我可以20小时不睡觉
我今天赶快趁现在
赶快好好研究股票
所以我要讲的是说
还没讲完
你看我现在都还没讲
是不是
你看连星星之我违星
又是赚钱的
违星也是喷出去的
对不对
是
违星是最烂的股票的
因為漲很少啊
好了我要趕快講了啦
不行了啦
納科也要噴出去的
記憶體趕快講
記憶體的納納科也要噴出去
沒錯吧
接下來最噴的會是我的群年好不好
現在納納科也是我的股票
我先講納科群年
好不好
我剛才有個會員說世界千金漲很慢
我真的想把他扒下去
漲4%就爛了
我想說奇怪
我記得世界千金不是拉尾盤嗎
你看到有人說世界千金漲很慢
你們會員是怎樣
你們可以冷靜一點嗎
一展股票一天展4% 你們覺得很爛
就因為他不像紅海一樣展停
你媽咧啦
我是股神 我現在是股神 但是股神
不代表我每一天是 現在是
你們不要要求那麼高好不好
半根展停板 你們不滿意
因為我是郭忠 是不是
剛才有沒有看到 是不是有人說世界千金展很棒
有沒有看到
依依你剛有看到吧
我想說世界千金是很爛是不是
你要拜託一下 今天展4%
你媽咧啦
這樣壓力很大雖然我很享受他
樊軒
不會啦樊軒跟金彩還是有機會噴出去
下禮拜都噴出去你就知道了好不好
金彩看起來知道噴的啦你們不要緊張啦
金彩跟樊軒看起來知道噴的啦
我選的股票都很漂亮
之後我要趕快告訴你的股票幾分呢
那個1
46了我趕快先開牌了
要不要先一下啦好不好
好學生
好學生是名詞動詞什麼
欸 莉莉你到底知不知道
這兩個股票
我
猜不出來 你股名也猜不出來
小孩你剛剛大概知道對不對
猜不出來
你們猜一下股票好不好
趕快猜一下
猜 有沒有猜
呃
猜一下你們覺得本來是什麼股票
你們可以猜
猜錯或故意猜錯都沒關係
我跟你們10秒鐘
寫一下好學生是什麼股票
呃 你不要猜
因為他今天大漲 你才猜
你從漲停去看 不要不要不要
你們猜一下
我跟你們10秒鐘的時間
你們寫一下
好不好 看留言一下
好不好
猜一下
欸我跟你講我跟妳互動有時候壓力很大
今天股票怎麼跌
今天股票有法說什麼
每次的人都問我問題
全年EPS35元
我告訴妳隔天文展平
欸不是每個人像哲哲反應能力那麼快欸
妳去看全台灣哪個老師
真材實料欸
每天都被考試
沒考試
好學是管達
為什麼管達
你看大部分人猜技嘉
技嘉 技嘉 技嘉 技嘉
華碩 華碩只是好學生
你看
唉呀
你看我對你們多好
胃口仰大
對啊展示牌 胃口仰大好不好
這跟大家講
學生要管學學友管大朋友
你看你們都猜到了
你們看今天展題猜到了
你看我隊你們多好
下次我去選一展
你們猜不到股票
如果一隊員寫技嘉
結果就是技嘉
你沒有猜到什麼意思
請你任命參加我會員好不好
不要每天猜好不好
這只好帥技嘉獎
這只我看到
這只我一笑到下週
是不是 錢都賺不完沒時間拆
這都會員朋友啦
好學生是名詞
但解答是動詞
很清楚耶 解答是動詞耶
好學生昨天還加碼耶
天啊 跟紅海一樣耶
我真的會員最愛死我了
今天馬上噴展庭啊
果然是整個好學生啊
我已經獲利了啊
獲利超過10%以上的
一根展庭板以上
果然是整個好學生有沒有看到
恭喜會員們成功讓大家賺大錢
有沒有看到
好學生 你們是我的好學生
則是你們老師
好學生不就是記家獎嗎
好學生不是記家獎嗎
不然要記大過是不是
下次壞學生叫什麼
叫記大
有這個股票喔
沒有這個股票啦
好學生
記家獎好不好
我跟你講 我這個人就是做事情認真負責任
我就是不要讓你覺得
我有任何一絲絲說完的可能性
跟你胡扯可能性
啊我真的很好
紅玉女孩就是紅海這個叫送分題
技嘉講技嘉也是送分題
有沒有
你們都很厲害
咕咕掌
看哲哲的節目自三都要自優生
IQ 130以上
很好
節目中找到透露有嗎
我不小心講錯話
好像有一天講到技嘉兩個字
來來來
這隻好幽默
謝謝大家
我笑了
有技嘉好不好
技高
技高沒有啦
技高人膽大
好來
聰明本性是管達嗎
不跟你講
管達什麼時候噴
管達我找掉
來有管達有偽串的去買紅海
當然我會變的
只是目前為止我告訴你
EPS 20元
我指的最強大
因為你知道股市有幾千個
一天幾千個訊息
可是我是過動了你知道嗎
我很喜歡閃爍那種訊息
我手機上去都發燙了
真的
因為我們公司老師最近也很紅
大家記憶都好
所以為什麼要講這東西
就是
我知道什麼是最重要的新聞
這個新聞很大
就是劉揚偉董事長
公安董事長如我所料這個
會犯利多啊這利多很大
所以他會再漲
OK嗎
OK啊
管達尾算是大盤3萬里的機器
但是20元的EPS是大利多
好不好
當然我覺得我一起漲
來
公共禁止比還算位階
這重點是你不要
你不要用禁止比啊
因為20元EPS算是大利多好不好
OK啊
就跟大家講
來
蛇神群零好弱
你看你看
一群粉絲來亂的
群零漲5%就好弱
你們現在很誇張
Lilya漲5%就好弱
1000萬一個一天賺50萬就好弱
你不要亂啦
我跟講叫你不要融資
那你可以O
可是你可以O in好不好
你買多一點就好了好不好
你不要來亂
我不想理你們了
你們這樣對我很高期待
趕快來參加我會好不好
最後一檔股票啦
來來趕快跟你講啦
沒有字卡喔
是好
聰明本性
這樣子是這樣聰明
來來來
還算聰明吧
不重要啦
賺錢比較實在
聰明本性這檔股票
我喜歡這字體
OK啊
人質出性本善
跟這有關係嗎
對啊笑死了
5%也不行是不是
胃口太大了是不是
5%也不行
你們不要這樣子
胃口都大了啦
一個5%一個4%都被人家罵了
你們不覺得你們很誇張嗎
好 我要去開會了
我跟你講
聰明本性這張股票
只有這張股票沒賺錢
說完會員
我剛剛到現在每個都稱讚我
有人說我說完話嗎
沒有啊
我幾千會員
如果說完話
應該網路上找到傳片的
對不對 沒錯吧
是
畫面給我
我幾千會員
幾萬次進出
幾十檔股票
沒有一檔賠錢
同一檔股票買低買高都賺錢
鴻海買低買高
環球金買低買高都賺錢
你去哪邊找這樣的老師啊
你不找我要找誰
鴻海還能所謂結冰啊
還能所謂結凍啊
所以你錯過鴻海 紅英女孩
你也錯過技嘉 技嘉獎
暫停板 暫停板 暫停板 暫停板
技嘉多少啊 再忙
你不能錯過
你不能錯過下一檔
聰明百姓
這是最優惠的專案
股票是永遠是最優惠的專案
不論對我錯説説説一切一切遇到前面
你想要標股
你看我會員現在都要求多高
5%算不行嗎
你看到我會員的見證我實力的時候
你趕快來念下去
080066 8085
0800來來 8085
加爾賴私詢我說説説説我要賺大錢
我會竭盡所人來賺大錢
向紅海掌停 向環球金
像國巨漲100%左右
賺100%左右
像年發科賺130 140
我不知道賺多少賺好多賺完美
我太激動了 我要結束了
太激動了 我愛你們
拜拜
通通都是假罵的喔
只有这三个账号
谢谢喔
投資人應獨立判斷